>> I HAVA QUTIVES BECAE FACEBOOE
AMAG KNOGEIN THE PT  ADVER THEY
WAY THINGS ARE ON PLATFOWE ENGA.
AS WE DIST SUMMER, WHEN ID,  T,N
ACCOUNT.
NG WITH NANCIAL
REPOG, THREE MONTHS WEALOF CONT
DOWN, HOTIFIEDAND
E DOING SOMETHING WHICH NO  I TY
AU ELSE IS D TNOS SEN OSE O  THN
INT BOARD TO
NSPARE W
CARPETICATIONS OF THAT RRCHOW WR
OFN,
NE ELIMINATE
U ER NEVER
BE TEENAGER WHDOOD EXPERIENCE IL
MEDIA BRINGS AOT
FEAR AMO LOT
A CE.LKS, INCLUDING PEOPLE WHOE
IS ANY ACCURAC
>> I WBEPEYOFOIDCH
ISBYOU THINK EVERYTHERE ARE JUS
WITH THE MOSISCACHLO H THE
N, TO BE OTOINTEGRITONOUYORE
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EER
THEMSETOR.K WEO RE
I THINK WEHAANY
ERS
TOING MORE TN
ANY D IT STI
ENOUGS ARREUR
BRAINS.
WE'R KIND OF
CONNECTIVITY AROUND THE WORLS T.
BUT IS THE PER
WHERE REGULATION WELP ONAN ISSR.
ONE OF PROBLEM H
OSTERESTTO
THST SENSITIVE
RR
CONTROLS.ALE RISKTAPEOPLE'S PRI
IF WAS TO BE IN CONGRESS ACE.
LAW THAT SAYLAFACEBOYOY,SK A TO
EXTERNALEAAV,
Y PROT TO OUR
TA>> ABOUT
S ANAL
UT AND SAID N IN
JOURNAL'S YSF
FACEBOOKAS CITED A SINGL
ERR IN OPIN ESS TH DECY ANPORTI
JOURNAL"TINGNTWILLE RELEASING A
ONS I ID, T
ROM THTSIDNY THAT  DSSRANDOMLY
ATETRE BE
EXPECTED TO
>> WE HAVE SHARED.
ALSO RN
PL ODATA, AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO
>>ERT TO JOU" APPARENTLY, "6
WH
WEENUSE CEOFUTRYYOUR RESPONS AR
>>E ASSERTIO
JANUARBEL  I JUST
TH.
VIOLENCE OJANU6t
INSURRECTI ON AT LIES
SQUARE WVI
WHO ENCOURAGED THEM, IDI-P IDLYD
ASSERTION THAT
THE ELEC W
, K E PEOPLEAD
ASSUME ERMUST BA FOE POLITIL O
>>ESTING.
K IT'S EASS FAULT? IASY EE AN RG
POLITICS WOULEV DISSOLVES PEOP
CULTURAL, SOCIMIC  LED TO THE PO
HE U.S.OKINCHERS K ATH
PUBLISWEEKS AGO BY SOMFORD
D NORTH AMERICA 12COUNTRS,
AND AUSTLID TO OF POLARION
T  AND THE
FOUND AN
HIGHER INCAS PAROVER THE PAST F
TO BE BECAUSOF SOM
E USI K ISLYIM B IA FACTOR, IT'
THE ORIGINAL C ARE YOU
WILLING TO A
CO THI SOME
EXCHAN TPLAC C OF THE
LARGEST SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
ITY TO RE WE CONTRIBUTE  NEGATET
D I HAVE EXPLAED TYOU
ME OF THE I THINK
AL
DONE TO BE DE
ORT CHECKERS ON
MAKSUIC TTIFY
OTHER CONTENT IS T M AND  HOOKEL
DOWN OUR NEWSFGHT,BILITYOUR RES.
BUT SSERTIONOF THE VIOLENCE THAN
DI SIMPLIFICATION OF THE
MU WNSCIETY
WHICH HAVE BEEN BREWING FOR A
AND I'M GLG
TH G TO BE
DOINTERVIEE OFTEN?
WILL ZUCKERBERG,DBERG?
T THE NEW PLANWILL YOUCONTINUE H
E, AMONGST OTHCOPOS PERF
PEEC RIGHT N I'M BART OF A
TEAM AND PART OF AM THAT, OF
ANSWERS TO MZUCKERBERG.I HOPE YS
E  EXECUTIVES  SSHH
E AVOIDING THE
UGH TIONS. THINK I'VE BEEN
UE HEREINONS.T ON THER
M WE AMPLTHOD ANDIZE THBAEDN EA
BEI CRITICISM --IT
RESPONSILITH SUCCESS COMES
WE SHOULD BEENOUGH TTICISM
WHERE THAT'S LITTLINATING
ALL TEENIMPLY NOT  THEITT  OR A
THAT'S ABSOLNOT WHAT THE SHOWS
I THINK IT'S VER I
'SSOME AND, TH
MI
OR PARENTS ACROSCO
THAT AND